por vientos de hasta 200 kilómetros por
hora sharon caos y estragos en todo el
norte de europa
la tormenta yunís llegó con fuerza el
viernes en el reino unido- los aviones
jumbo se vieron obligados a luchar
contra el clima extremo en sus intentos
de aterrizar en el aeropuerto de
heathrow trenes fueron cancelados y el
suministro de energía eléctrica
interrumpido en todo el país además de
producirse importantes daños en el
emblemático ochoa ruina de londres las
condiciones adversas obligaron a las
autoridades a emitir alertas
meteorológicas rojas que indican peligro
para la vida algunas zonas del sur de
inglaterra incluida la capital
es la primera vez que la oficina
meteorológica emite una alerta roja en
nuestra capital de allí subir ese
supuesto la tormenta yunís es el peor
temporal al que nos hemos enfrentado en
tres décadas
aunque el reino unido fue el más
afectado otras partes del norte de
europa también sintieron la fuerza de
yunís varias ciudades del norte de
francia sufrieron el embate de enormes
olas en sus costas en ámsterdam
los caídos bloquearon las carreteras y
se instó a los residentes de todo el
país a permanecer en casa al otro lado
del mar de irlanda se produjeron escenas
de caos similares en wexford en el
sureste del país un hombre de unos 50
años que intentaba limpiar los escombros
murió al ser golpeado por la caída de un
árbol
se levantó y salió a ayudar a la gente
lo mejor que pudo no sabía que no
volvería a casa con su familia esta
noche sanz le exime el número de
víctimas mortales de yunís asciende
ahora al menos a nueve ya que también
han muerto personas en el reino unido
los países bajos y bélgica